[Music]
[Applause]
he is the Monday Morning Quarterback
always makes us smarter always great to
see Albert Breer the senior NFL reporter
from the Monday Morning Quarterback yes
here he is yep
yep what's up guys how about that Albert
Breer he's an NFL Insider by the way hey
Dan how we doing when you when you I
didn't expect the studio audience but
that's a nice touch when you when you
file your taxes do you put Insight like
is your job an Insider there I think I
think I just put reporter reporter yeah
yeah yeah I think I just put reporter uh
the first time you were recognized do
you remember like oh I've seen you on TV
yeah it was probably like when I was it
was probably and I was still working at
the uh Suburban paper in Massachusetts
where I was covering at the same time
both the Patriots and high schools so I
had to juggle the two which was a little
complicated and I started doing a little
TV work up there and I think it was like
at a bar on a Friday night or something
like that and it was weird you know what
I mean cuz I I've always seen like what
I do for a living is kind of
stupid because I think like I don't
think like like a bunch of grown-ups
playing like I don't think a bunch bunch
of grown-ups playing kids game is the
most serious thing in the world so what
I'm doing for a living really isn't very
serious
um so yeah I mean I it's it's always
interesting when people I mean I'm sure
you get a lot more than I do so yeah but
when you're when you're around the other
insiders yeah like do you social I mean
how much compet when you see Ian
Rapaport or Jay Glazer I'm friendly with
all of them yeah I'm friendly with all
of them I mean I think there's I I think
that there's an understanding and
respect for how much goes into it you
know and I wouldn't say like there's no
information sharing I mean like I think
we do talk about things and like a lot
of times um with the guys that I'm close
with you know you'll tell backstories of
stuff that happened a month ago you know
what I mean like so like there'll be a
backstory to this story or that story
that came out and um and so you can tell
the backstory of something like that's
like a month old or two months old but
obviously there's the stuff that's
competitive too yeah but everybody
rushes to be the first yeah that's
competition yeah has anybody stole
something from you that happens a lot
yeah I mean there's stuff that you're
holding on to where you're like could
you take Adam
shefer well I have the I have reach on
him right yeah yeah and rap aport you
got reach on him I got reach on him I
mean that's the funny thing is like you
talk about being recognized right what I
get more than anything else is like
you're much I got this on the elevator
at the hotel last night my God you're
way taller than I thought you'd be
Paulie said that to me this morning he
goes Albert Brier's taller than I
thought yeah because everybody expects
like all of us to be 5 foot4 yeah cuz a
lot of us
are
speaking of glazer do you think that was
cold yeah you could have picked one of a
number of people there you picked on J
that is true that is true uh but yeah
Glazer could take everybody though in
the octave yeah I don't I don't think
it' be a smart idea to don't want to
mess with him all right what did the
commissioner say last night that fans
should care about I I think the playing
surface thing is going to continue to be
a story and the story here in in Vegas
with what H what's happening with the
ners um it's kind of funny cuz you know
what I had heard what happened out there
at UNLV um they laid grass down over a
turf field and that's why it's spongy
and slippery right and I think the NFL
might have messed with the wrong team on
this because that is the most militant
team when it comes to playing surfaces
and Kyle Shanahan's very serious about
it and if I've talked to Nick Bosa about
it a bunch and he thinks it's horse you
know what that they're forced to play on
artificial turfy of course towards ACL
at meti um 3 years ago um
when he looks across the Atlantic Ocean
and sees the way that European soccer
players are treated so after the story
last year right like with the slippery
surface in Arizona the fact that the
field here is the same right because
they've got the roll out field and then
of course what's happening with the ners
right now where the Niners might
actually move one of their practices
later this week to avoid playing on what
they've been assigned to at UNLV right I
think this is going to be a story all
week and it's part a much larger story
in the NFL and then of course the
gambling stuff which I mean like a
complete 180 on what they were saying in
2012 2014 and so you know the
incorporation of gambling I mean hell
Caesar's name is on a stadium in the
league right now um the incorporation of
gambling into the NFL community and how
important a piece of everything it is
for the owners now like David teer
literally bought the Panthers when he
bought the Panthers because he was like
legalized gambling's about to happen
everywhere it's going to going to juice
the valuations of all these teams
gambling I think is going to be a big
story all week are we going to see all
the stadiums where you have a kiosk that
that you can go and like like you know
the premier league has that where you
can bet and everything is I mean I would
put it all Under One Roof you know the
Cubs have there's there's certain
baseball teams I think have this the but
the Premier League you can go gamble
there and go watch the game right well I
think what I think what Vegas has taught
them right and you'll see this elsewhere
now like here in Vegas with with the
Raiders their competition to get butts
in the seats is a sports book right so
their competition to get people into the
stadium and watching their games is the
idea that you can just go to a casino
and watch all the games and bet on
whatever you want yeah so they have to
give you what you're getting somewhere
else in the stadium and that's where I
think the dam sort of broke you know
what I mean and if you have sports books
now in every NFL city which eventually
will probably get there well then that's
going to be the competition for them to
get people in and at a time when it's
harder and harder and harder to for
teams to get fans into those seats right
like we know that um that you got to
give them what they can get outside and
one of the things they're going to be
able to get outside almost everywhere
pretty soon is the ability to bet on all
the games he's Albert Breer the Monday
Morning Quarterback senior NFL reporter
explain to me what happened with the
commanders um yeah with the coaching
search and what happened with Eric
benemy
uh was belich in the mix there you know
11th hour I mean where wherever you want
to start here I would say like one of
the things that Josh Harris and his
group really focused on was structure
and I think that's one of the reasons
why belich didn't fit into it in fact I
think like overall owner Obsession now
with looking at different structures
across all of sports in soccer in
basketball um you know Josh Harris
obviously owns a basketball team owns
the Sixers so they a lot of these teams
have looked very intensely at structure
and I think I think that's why like the
the all powerful head coach the bill
bich the Mike Fel had much more trouble
finding work in this cycle is because
it's like okay like so before I've hired
the people I've I've set up the
structure and does this type of Coach
fit into that structure or is this type
of Coach valuable enough where I want to
fit the structure around him and I think
a lot of these owners now are picking
the structure over the coach which I'd
argue might not be the best way to do it
but that's the way they decided to do it
so they hire Adam P ERS um very very
quickly and they were efficient about
that they got him within the first week
and they wanted to be wide open about
their process so they had Zoom
interviews with um I believe it was
eight candidates they brought seven of
them back for in-person interviews and
they wanted to be open-minded about it
Raheem Morris almost got the job two
weeks ago very close to getting the job
two weeks ago the Falcons gave him an
offer and that made the commanders
really think and they now you know we
want to finish our process we want to
meet with everybody they were obviously
interested in meeting with Ben Johnson
um that didn't go so well um on Monday
with the way that they got the news
there and then the final two were Mike
McDonald and and Dan Quinn and Seattle
swooping in and grabbing McDonald sort
of clarified simplified things did they
want Dan Quinn did they sell they love
Dan Quinn yeah like they do but they
settle for Dan there are a lot of common
connections there though Adam Peters
came from San Francisco a lot of the
coaches in San Francisco worked under
Dan Quinn in Atlanta so Kyle Shanahan
was Dan Quinn's offensive coordinator so
Quinn
like the references were great he
knocked the interview out of the park is
it as exciting at higher as Raheem
Morris or um you know or Ben Johnson Ben
Johnson or Mike McDonald would have been
you know maybe not but Dan Quinn
somebody who was in De demand the last
couple of years so I think settled the
wrong settle's the wrong word I think
it's they were just kind of committed to
riding the entire process Out and
because of that they lost a couple of
guys along the way
does belich coach in the NFL again yes I
think he coaches in 2025 um I think you
know again like I I think the fear with
belich and Vel and I think it's not a
great commentary on the NFL and how NFL
teams operate that those guys couldn't
get work that you had eight openings and
Bill bich who's the greatest of all time
and Mike Fel who I think was a top
quarter of the league like a top eight
coach or so in the in in the league over
the last few years couldn't get work I
think again it comes back to that thing
about like what owners want and what
owners want right now is a that sort of
structure that we talked about and B and
this sounds so stupid but it's true they
want it to be like fun to come into work
you know what I mean like and how like
it sounds dumb right like that that's
your priority but like a lot of these
guys are like well I bought the team I
didn't buy the team to be uninvolved and
they're afraid like in hiring somebody
like belich maybe they'll be frozen out
of everything you know and um so like I
think that that was a real Factor and I
but I think after a year what we're
going to see is we're going to see some
of these things fail and then some
people like like anything else then
we're going to see a couple of teams say
well you know like say the Patriots go 4
and 13 it's like oh maybe it wasn't all
him maybe there were other problems
there but then you look at the body of
work and it's like yeah the problem with
Bill the problem bill has right now Dan
is
that if you have to blow everything up
for him right if you have to do so much
to get him if you have to maybe move
some people out to get him are you doing
do that for 24 months are you doing that
for 36 months you know what I mean and
that's the issue and I think the
challenge for bill will be a showing he
can work with a variety of different
people right which I think there's a
perception that he can't and
B giving whoever the owner is the exit
strategy like hey here's what it's going
to look like when I leave and here like
I'm going to put your next coach on my
staff I'm going to do things so in 24 36
months when I walk away because I'm 75
years old at that point you're not going
to be dead as a franchise for having had
me here see I thought the Eagles were
going to maybe pull the trigger on Bill
yeah because they did everything but
fire Nick serani y Mike McCarthy you
know Jerry G to give him another shot
but it feels like he's got one shot and
those two would make sense because those
two have veteran teams right and those
two have established structures where
they're not looking for something new
you know so it's like we can plug bill
into this and it's not going to blow
everything up bill has a relationship
with hoe Roseman right so so I like
working relationship is different who
knows how that would work out but there
is a relationship there bill has a very
close relationship with Jerry and
Stephen Jones people don't realize that
like there is a lot of mutual respect
there um and I think that that was a
thought for the Cowboys you know and I
do think like you look at their roster
they're another team that's sort of in
this win now position and I mean one
thing about having an owner so involved
like Jerry and Steven are involved in
Dallas is it makes it so that there
aren't these layers of management
between the coach and the owner I
actually think and some people in some
ways people are like you people like wow
you know would that work with the
medling it's like maybe it would be an
issue like maybe there'd be some
friction but at least you've got a
direct the coach has a direct line to
the owner there there's not like all of
this clutter around the relationship
Caleb Williams going to go number one I
think so yeah I mean I why is there this
confusion that there's been misreporting
it feels like or Wishful reporting that
maybe he says doesn't want to go to the
Bears I mean I I think it's cuz of his
dad um now but is that true that he
might not want to go to the Bears I mean
I I think it's something that I would
say a lot of the crazy stuff that you've
heard like right like so there was stuff
about the equity like wanting equity in
a team right like which was I mean bad
we you know I mean like like but I think
a lot of that stuff was coming from his
dad and he can't get Equity no no and
what what what all these teams are what
all these teams are sort of looking like
cuz when they when the Scouts go into
USC what they're hearing from the
teammates what they're hearing from the
coaches Cliff Kingsbury was one of them
like they all love him they love him as
a kid but there's all this noise around
him and so the challenge for the Bears
for the commanders for everybody else is
like cutting through that and seeing all
right like when he gets here what's it
going to be is there still going to be
this noise or is the kid that the USC
players that the USC coaches that the
Oklahoma coaches that the Oklahoma
players were around is that what we're
getting um um it's going to be
interesting because I do think I mean
look like the Washington storyline is
not going to die they hired Cliff
Kingsbury he grew up in Washington he
went to high school in the District of
Columbia so the idea that Washington
could move up to go and get him like
that's a storyline that's not going to
go away and if Washington assesses him
as being that much better than Drake May
or Jaden Daniels well then do they move
Heaven and Earth to try and do it and
how do the bears react to that
why didn't the Bears hire Cliff
kingsburry as their offensive
coordinator I think the Bears got the
best offensive coordinator in the cycle
um it's a fair question it would have
been a pretty funny tell to Justin
Fields what you were doing um but I I I
think the bear I give the Bears a lot of
credit for what they did because um I
think Shane walr would have had three
four five offers I think he was the most
attractive offensive coordinator
candidate on the market and on paper
that's not a great job on paper it's
like Matty Eber flu and Ryan poles could
get fired in the year
um but they got ahead of the market and
so while these other teams are
considering quote unquote considering
Shane Waldren and maybe would have
offered him three four five days later
the Bears came with an offer and got
them so um the Bears are still assessing
things but I think the likelihood is
they take Caleb number one in trade J
I'll leave you with this uh how
important is the rock to the spring
League working like what is the success
of the spring lead League going to uh
hinge on I think the success of the
spring league and I think one of the
things that like the Rock and the other
people that are involved um can do is is
build relationships with people at the
NFL they need the support of the NFL I
think that much is clear we've seen
enough of these leagues wash out um the
NFL needs a minor league they need a
developmental League you know especially
with what's happening at college
football and you know like you get some
of these kids that are transferring to
two and three schools then coming into
the league they're less developed
they're more raw there's more work that
needs to be done and you know especially
with the quarterback issue Dan like one
of the biggest reasons why we had so
many quarterback injuries this year and
one of the reasons why we've seen so
many quarterback injuries the NFL is
doing the NFL is having real trouble
developing offensive linemen yeah and
it's because at the college level
they're playing in the spread so a lot
of the offenses just stand up and hold
your block for one second and then the
ball's out right and so then you get
this kid who's Raw coming out of college
and all the rules now in the NFL around
practice in the spring in the summer and
then into the season limit contact well
who does that affect that affects the
offense linemen especially the backups
who aren't playing in games so the NFL
has to better has to do a better job of
developing backup linemen do a better
job at developing backup quarterbacks
and I think having a league like that
the way NFL Europe once was can really
be beneficial the question is will they
help invest in you know what's going on
with the spring League now to make it
work and if the people who are running
the spring League can foster that
relationship and get that relationship
to a point where the NFL will invest
then maybe it can succeed always great
to see you abely thanks for joining us
he's Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback we'll take a break play of
the day is up next here on The Dan
Patrick Show